es ist keine Überraschung während der
corona-krise ist der Alkoholkonsum
gestiegen besonders unter Berufstätigen
wer ist eine neue Studie zeigt die
Mehrheit sagt sie können so besser den
Stress abbauen und auch die Kranken Tage
wegen Alkohol erreichen einen
Höchststand während Corona
trinkkarnation Deutschland Frust trinken
statt Genuss trinken heckklässler
abschalten mit einem Glas Rotwein willst
du da schon gefährlich ich hoffe nicht
weil ich das sehr oft mache also ich
komme aus der Pfalz ich trinke gerne
Weinen das gehört für mich auch schon
zum zum Genuss dazu aber wie geht's dir
glaube ich um wirklich schweren
Alkoholgenuss Alkohol Missbrauch
teilweise schon und bewerbungswert ist
natürlich schon dass es vor allem die
Berufstätigen in diesem Falle trifft
also nicht die jetzt unter den Brücken
liegen also die nichts mehr erwarten von
mir 30 und 39 dann Anstieg um fast 89 %.
unsere Leistungselite im Leben steht
vielleicht Familie hat nicht mehr im
ersten Job sondern zweiten schon hat
karriereschrittmacht ich hoffe nur dass
Sie hier bei uns nicht diese sogenannte
russische Krankheit ausbreitet und
trinken vor allem die Männer ja wirklich
die Birne weg weil sie das Leben dort
nicht aushalten weil sie perspektivlos
sind und ich glaube das deswegen muss
man diese Zahlen zu ernst nehmen ich
glaube wir hätten eine Situation wie
jetzt damit nicht fertig wird dafür habe
ich nämlich Verständnis wenn es dazu
einem dauerhaften gewöhnungs- und
dauerhaften Gewöhnungseffekt wird ein
Rausch wenn ich also sag ich kann mein
Leben nur noch im Rausch ertragen dann
bricht uns wirklich eine Schicht Weg die
eigentlich der Futter das Fundament
unserer Gesellschaft wäre wie ist es in
der Politik ich habe ein super Zitat ähm
mir notiert das kommt von ihrem Partei
genossen Joschka Fischer wahrscheinlich
kennen sie es auch wenn schon eine Weile
her ist der sagt der Bundestag ist eine
unglaubliche alkoholikerversammlung die
teilweise ganz ordinär nach Schnaps
stinkt je länger die Sitzung dauert
desto intensiver
ich glaube dass das in den Zeiten wo man
noch nicht so im Bild war also jetzt
kann man ja alles auch Phoenix Anschauen
von bis morgens bis abends noch mehr
gang und gäbe war dass dann getrunken
wurde auch in den Kneipen und man dann
in den Bundestag hineinmarschiert ist
und das einem keinen aufgefallen ist
wenn man dann sozusagen nicht mehr alle
Sinne beisammen hatte ich glaube heute
hoffe ich zumindest bei den allermeisten
Kollegen dass das verstanden wird dass
das sich nicht ziehen und ich will auch
sagen ich trinke auch Alkohol durchaus
auch manchmal vielleicht mehr als ich
sollte aber ich habe schon für mich ein
Einstellungswandel vollzogen also wir
haben halt so eine Kulturnation mit
Alkohol in Deutschland aufgebaut als ich
angefangen habe zu arbeiten weil bei der
Post und später auch mein Bayerischen
Rundfunk da gab es noch Bier Automaten
dann hat man das zweite Frühstück
gemacht mit dem Weißbier und heute ist
das undenkbar Gott sei Dank also es muss
die Leute schon aufklären und sagen es
ist nicht unbedingt cool du brauchst das
nicht wenn du das machen willst ist
deine eigene Verantwortung aber so dass
es so ein kulturellen Zwang gibt ich
meine z.B momentan weil ich das kriegt
meine Arbeit sonst nicht hin meine
momentan Zusammenkünfte wo man Alkohol
die gibt es ja hier im politischen
Berlin jeden Abend und ja vielleicht
nach der Sendung mal doch mal ein Bier
aber dann ist auch gut ja also das muss
also dass man kann sehr viel trinken
wenn man möchte jederzeit und das ist
verlockend und viele sagen die
Krankenkassen haben jetzt echt Alarm
geschlagen sie brauchen das in den
Stress abzubauen und den Alltag zu
vergessen machen sich da Sorgen dass die
Menschen so unter der Krise leiden dass
das im ernsthaften Sorgen dass die Leute
nur noch negative Nachrichten sehen und
es war jetzt auch ein schweres Jahr mal
wieder wenn das ist jetzt mit dem Krieg
mit den Energiepreise mit der Inflation
auf der anderen Seite sind wir in Land
in hohen Wohlstand wir müssen auch
wieder ein bisschen mehr über die
positiven Dinge reden die ist auch in
diesem Land gibt sich von gestern
Wolfgang Schäuble sehr gut bei uns der
auch mal gesagt hat also er kennt jetzt
50 Jahre Bundestag und es ist nicht die
schlimmste Zeit die wir in der Nation
erlebt haben wir hatten auch schon
andere Zeiten und ähm ja natürlich den
Menschen
Rückblick was noch mal schlimmer das ist
natürlich denen die jetzt da vor dem
Winter arbeitet daran dass ich den
Leuten Moden mache und ich Angst mache
und das wissen vielleicht ein paar mehr
machen ja aus dem Handwerk Herr Schröder
da könnte es ja auch wenn es gerade
gehört das Weißbier oder das Bier das
schon mit dem Kasten eigentlich bereit
steht da gehörte das ja auch lange Zeit
dazu auf einer Baustelle oder im Betrieb
hat sich das auch so verändert wie im
Bundestag ist letztlich kannst die Welt
wo ich rumlaufe aber die Handwerker die
ich kennengelernt habe passen nicht mehr
zu diesem Klischee ich glaube das ist
das erfreuliche dass wir heute also
sowohl unter Jugendlichen als auch unter
Erwachsenen auch eben gegen Entwicklung
halt feststellen
Alkoholmissbrauch ist immer ein Zeichen
für das was nicht richtig läuft und ich
glaube was wir dabei sehen müssen ist
Einsamkeit für viele Menschen sind
entweder mit sich selbst einsam
zum Beispiel aus der Krise oder sie sind
in Gruppe einsam das finde ich
eigentlich viel schlimmer nicht dass
Menschen eigentlich in diese Situation
hineinkommen dass sie dann miteinander
zusammen sind aber eigentlich sehen dass
einer gerade wegbricht ja also wenn man
in seiner unter seinen Kollegen sieht
dass einer nicht mehr nur eine Genuss
hat nicht den pfälzischen Weingenuss
sondern sich nur noch die Dröhnung gibt
und selbst Chefs nicht mehr sehen dass
alles komplett schief läuft das macht
mir doch schon Sorgen trotzdem möchte
ich es mal sagen oder als ein Bild zu
bleiben etwa etwas Wein ins Wasser zu
gießen also hat ja auch Umgang ab und zu
mit Parlamentarier und spricht ab und zu
auch mit denen es ist nicht so dass der
Bundestag zu alkoholfreien Zone gewonnen
die Belastung dort ist sehr sehr hoch
machs gut oder schlecht macht ist
erstmal wurscht es ist Arbeitsbelastung
ist enorm hoch ist ein totaler Stress
Job und sehr viele davon trinken auch
einige zu viel einige normal einige gar
nicht aber der der trifft zum Alkohol
ist also jetzt im Bundestag alles andere
als verpönt das heißt ja auch wie viele
Kilo bist du schon im Bundestag also das
geht dann nicht die Jahre sondern die
Kilo und wenn man da mal reinkommt
Gummibärchen schlechtes Essen fettiges
Essen
das kann man nur sagen muss man vor
Waden und die Leute auch die neue
reinkommen die ist noch nicht so kennen
aber aufmerksam machen hier Wolfgang das
zeigt auch man bekommt als Politiker
Zara ständig was angeboten also gleich
Insekt Empfang in der Früh irgendwann
gibt es ein Bier dann gibt es auch noch
ein Schnaps es geht die ganze Zeit so
weiter es gibt aber auch einfach viele
Dinge vielleicht die man sich fast schon
schön trinken muss das Interessante ist
ja auch an dieser Studie dass die schon
quasi 2011 begann also eigentlich eine
Krise nacheinander flüchtlingskrise
Klimakrise corona-krise Energiekrise der
Krieg also jede Krise ist eine Krise für
uns Menschen zu viel vor allem die die
auch berufstätig sind und sowieso schon
unter gewissen stressleiden im Alltag
und anscheinend ist es gar nicht mehr zu
stemmen in diesen dauerkrisenmodus in
dem wir uns befinden und ich frag mich
auch ehrlich gesagt ob das die richtige
Zeit ist auch demnächst Cannabis zu
legalisieren wenn wir solche Studien
haben indem immer mehr Menschen gezielt
aus der Realität verschwinden wollen
dass dieser immer krasserin Realitäten
der wir uns befinden ich meine was für
Bilder wir auch immer sehen aus dem
Ukraine kriegt verständliche Bilder oder
woanders außer auf der Welt das ist ja
nicht nur so dass wir in Europa Krieg
haben und Unternehmer haben und ich
glaube diese diese krasse
kriseneinwirkung wirklich führt dazu
dass immer mehr Menschen sich immer mehr
in weg von der Realität flüchten wollen
zum Beispiel mit Cannabis dass ihre
Partei legalisieren will ist das ein
guter Zeitpunkt ich glaube das ist
richtig ist weil die Menschen Cannabis
sowieso konsumieren das machen sie halt
jetzt illegal hier in Berlin oder in
München wo ich herkomme und es ist
besser dieses Substanzen zu
kontrollieren vielleicht auch zu
besteuern Aufklärung zu machen als
diesen Schwarzmarkt zu haben der ja dann
auch die Lippen Cannabis mit anderen
Drogen vermischt also ich das ist immer
das Argument aber ich finde jetzt gerade
im Zusammenhang mit dieser Studie wo man
sieht es aus offenbar schon den Drang
gibt den Stress loszuwerden den Stress
irgendwie abzubauen dass man danach
Mitteln und Wegen sucht das würde aber
auch bedeuten das könnte sich ja auch
auf Cannabiskonsum ganz anders auswirken
als erwartet wenn die Menschen genauso
derzeit mit ihren Alter das Problem
nicht dass sie Leute haben die
Drogenkonsum nicht beherrschen können
und manche in seinem Lebensweg hat sich
diese Zeiten vielleicht auch schon
erlebt und ich glaube ich würde sogar
sagen eine Cannabis Droge dann die kann
gut konsumiert sein indem man sie halt
milde anwendet man kann sich das
aussuchen man muss ja auch nicht ein
Schnaps trinken sondern ein Bier oder
ein alkoholfreies Bier und so ist dann
auch ja ich habe schon Cannabis geraucht
und ich würde mich auch wahrscheinlich
sogar etwas wegbewegen vom Alkohol wenn
die Cannabis Legalisierung kommt ja
alles klar meine persönliche Aussage
interessant eigentlich also für Cannabis
sind und Cannabis legalisieren wollen
wenn man solche Studie betrachtet dann
schaffen die es ja auch irgendwie ist es
ja angeblich dann auch legitim quasi und
verharmlos ein bisschen die Droge
Cannabis die ja auch viele
Nebenwirkungen hat und auch eine
Einstiegsdroge ist auch an für andere
Drogen die härter sind
gerade in so einem Zustand sind wo wir
uns eh alle mehr von der Realität
wegfliegt aber wenn wir das Vergleichen
und wir wollen ja nicht Alkohol
verbieten in diesem Land aber Alkohol
ist noch mal die deutlich
gefährden wollen
also wir haben ja gerade gesehen sie
haben berichtet vom Genuss des Weins und
deswegen werden sie ja nicht zum Wein
Alkoholiker wenn sie ihn genießen und
die Leute die jetzt in diesen Alkohol
Missbrauch reinkommen haben wir ja
gerade gesehen dass ich der Alkohol die
Ursache ist sondern der Stress im Job
die Überlast die Vereinsamung die die
völlige Überforderung nicht und wenn man
dann sagt ja dann sollten wir den
Alkohol verbieten sage ich ja damit
löste das Problem der Überforderung
nicht nicht geht die Leute nur nach
Hause zahlen sich ja was mache ich jetzt
nachher werden Sie vielleicht aggressiv
irgendwohin und dann wenn du keinen
Alkohol trinkst bist schon blöd
angeschaut ist ja selbst in der
Arbeitswelt manchmal so aber
ist einfach die Summe der verfügbaren
Rauschmittel erhöhen das würde ja
geschehen kann bis frei geben würde ich
bin der auch zwiegespalten als Liberaler
Mensch würde ich sagen das nicht machen
aber in der jetzigen Situation noch eine
Droge die auch Suchtpotenzial hat sagen
ja auch Ärzte freigegeben halte ich
jetzt doch schon für sehr riskant und
ich bin mir nicht sicher ob das schon
alles letzte Hand abgewogen